tourists have flocked to China's
freezing Northern provinces to enjoy
winter attractions such as harbin's
famous ice City and the snow covered ski
slopes of leing travel data shows winter
tourism here is up 30% compared to a
year ago bringing a much needed boost to
businesses it's a rare bright spot in
China's slowing economy the government
says the country beat its Target of 5%
growth for 2023 achieving
5.2% but that figure is still one of the
lowest in decades and the outlook for
2024 remains shaky at the world economic
Forum in Davos China's Premier
downplayed
concerns the Chinese economy is making
steady progress and will continue to
provide strong Inus for the world
Economic Development Chinese officials
say the economy will improve in the
coming months visitors to beijing's
historical CH High Lake are feeling
positive I am from China's warmer South
and rarely get the chance to see eyes
I'm having a lot of
fun I brought my son here to enjoy
himself the Ice Festival in the
Northeast is very popular this year we
can't go but we can get similar
experience here it's the first winter
since 2019 that tourists have been able
to enjoy without fear of covid-19
lockdowns these types of winter sports
and activities aren't traditionally part
of Chinese culture but since Beijing won
the 2022 Winter Olympics their
popularity has
soar the government is banking on the
trend continuing over the upcoming Luna
New Year holiday with a record 9 billion
trips predicted over the 40-day travel
period however analysts say a boost in
tourism is unlikely to solve bigger
problems such as a crisis in the
property Market some of the people have
spent more on things like tourism uh
cultural activities like concerts or
they would buy more uh consumer goods
but overall on the savings rate is still
going
up but for those enjoying themselves
here the economy is the furthest thing
from their minds Katrina U Al jaaz
Beijing make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer